[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
top tips for achieving compliance for
laboratory balances
i am kaylee bach of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by sartorius
to learn more about our sponsor visit
sartorius.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr holger denzo
product manager at sartorius
for a full biography of our speaker
please see the biography tab on your
screen
dr denzo you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much for joining today's
webinar about
compliance for laboratory balances
the webinar will be presented by dr
holger denzo product manager for premium
balances at sartorius and me sebastian
weber product manager for software
solutions at sartorius
and
it's divided in two parts
in the first part of the webinar we
explain how to achieve data integrity
minimize risk and the potential for fda
violations and how digital workflows can
be supported by technologies like the
cubist 2 lab balance
the second part of the presentation
highlights important news for the
pharmaceutical industries
the new chapter
2.1.7 of the european pharmacopoeia is
compared with the usp chapter 41.
the difference are highlighted and
software solutions discussed to ensure
compliance
we will now start with a part of data
integrity
why is data integrity so important in
the pharmaceutical industry
because
all of our decisions are based on data
and when we have incorrect or wrong data
we make maybe wrong decisions based on
this information
and this increase the risk of
compromising our product safety and
quality
and can have negative impact
on our product itself and more important
on our patients health and safety
and when we risk our patients health and
safety
it can break the trust between patients
the inspectors
stakeholders
and we can lose brand reputation
and therefore it's very important that
we make the right decision
based on correct data
so what is data integrity exactly so
with data integrity we want to cover two
major goals one is to ensure that the
data is recorded exactly as intended so
maybe when we transfer value from the
instrument
to our laboratory system like in lims or
elm
and on the other hand we want to ensure
that the data reminds the same as when
it was originally recorded over its
entire life cycle what can be in the
pharmaceutical industries
more than 20 years
and the principle of data integrity also
applies to handwritten records
or hybrid system like
when you transfer your data manually
from
an instrument to an excel notebook
or to a lymph system so it's not only a
topic what came with computerized system
but when you use a computerized system
and you have this kind of seamless
transfer from an instrument
to this computerized system
you will see in this presentation that
it's much easier
to fulfill all the data integrity
requirements and follow the principles
then when you work completely manually
so the data integrity is on hot topic in
the pharmaceutical industry
you can also see when you take a look in
the fda warning letters
so for example in 2019 65 of all fda
warning letters
contains data integrity issues
and this
are different types of issues
some of them are more related to the
instrument itself for example
to have a not um
audit trail enabled or an insufficient
audit rail
the other ones are more related to the
documentation process
like not all relevant data was recorded
or the
data was not recorded in a way
that it's tamper-proof for example
and yeah i would like to show you now in
the next minutes
different types of data integrity
violations what can be found in fda
warning ledgers
and how you can
prevent them with a modern laboratory
instrument with workflow guidance and
all the required features for data
integrity and compliance like our cubist
2 balance from zaturias
so my first example shows you directly
why a digital workflow guidance can help
you to prevent data integrity issues and
on the other hand helps you to bring
more efficiency in your laboratory work
so in this finding
all the data from the instrument was
first recorded in an official
spreadsheet and then later transcribed
to an official form or system
and
also in this finding was mentioned
that
the spreadsheet showed falling results
above the limits the company established
in their procedure
and here it's a very good example when
you have a digital workflow you can make
sure that everyone has follow the
procedure or your sop
to generate a trusted data record
so the workflow can on one hand
automatically record the measured values
if needed
you can define in the workflow
calculations so the user have not to do
calculations manually and this also
prevents a lot of
arrow potential
and at least the digital workflow can
also evaluate results and check if the
results are within the given limits or
specification
so
you can make sure with the digital
guidance that all your procedures are
followed and the data is directly
recorded
here in the example with the cubist2
balance you see we have these guidance
with our q apps directly on the balance
screen so the user gets all the
information what he has to do
on the screen
and if there is any
calculation we can perform it directly
on the instrument
we can then also show the user at the
end the results before he prints the
results or send it for example to the
lymph system
yeah our next fda finding is a quite
common one
so
here it is possible
that
a user
logs in wire shared account for example
operator or administrator into a system
and can
create data or change system settings
without traceability
and therefore
you should make sure that the
computerized system can only use with a
personalized user account so that you
exactly can see who make some changes in
the system or who generates data on the
system
and on the other hand this user account
should also be protected by a strong
password for the authentication
and we recommend
that this password should follow your
company rules so therefore it should not
be given by the device manufacturer it
should be possible to adapt these
password rules to your company needs
yeah in an optimal case
you have an instrument integration into
your company domain
so that the user can use the same
password as he used typically to log on
onto windows
this makes it on one hand easier for
the
administration because you only maintain
the user accounts in your company um
domain
and on the other hand it's also easier
for the users because they have only to
remember one password and not a separate
password for each instrument
so for example with cubist2 we have the
possibility to directly integrate the
balance into your company network via
ldap so that the user can log on on the
balance instrument with their
personalized
domain
user accounts
yeah the next problem is also a very
common one regarding user management or
user accounts
and this is when a user has too much
rights on a computerized system
and can use this right to manipulate
data or experiments result
so in this warning letter for example
the analyst has a possibility to change
the system date and time
and use this for
setting the clock back to repeat some
analysis
and um yeah to prevent these kind of
issues you should make sure that each
user account has also
only the rights what
it's needed for
the work so you should also make sure
that an administrative user has only
administrative rights and that's a
possibility to perform any analysis and
on the other hand
the laboratory operator or technician
has only the right to perform analysis
but not rights for making them changes
on the system
yeah but this um
fda finding shows also another important
thing and this is that you have also
every time the correct time for your um
to your results
and to make this show we also recommend
that you have an automatic time
synchronization feature for your
instrument so that you can make sure
that your instrument or your
computerized system runs always with the
correct time
in the next morning later here
the fda mentioned the importancy of the
audit trail in their warning ledger
so they write directly the use of other
trails for computerized analytical
instrumentation is essential to ensure
the integrity and reliability of the
electronic data generated
and therefore you should always make
sure
that your computerized system has an
audit trail
that it's always be activated
um we from the tutorials on our cubist 2
balance for example have always the
audit trail activated and it cannot be
disabled or deleted
and
you should not only have the audit trail
what documents all
the important events on the instrument
you should also review the audit trail
entries in a regular way
so you should have an sop in place
where you described these
audit trail reviews and also documents
or audit trail reviews
and
also
it's important
that the review of the auto trailer is
easy for you
and therefore it should have a sort
filter and also an export function from
the instrument that you convenient
review the data and also with the export
function to archive the auditorial data
easily
in the next slide i only copy
one sentence from an fda warning letter
and this is laboratory records failed to
include signatures
we know for a trusted record it must be
signed by the individual who creates a
record
and this applies for paper-based record
also for
electronic records
and
the good thing is with an electronic
workflow we can to make sure
that this is fulfilled because we can
easily say
at the end of the workflow after a
review of the data the individual has to
sign before the record is created so
it's also a very good example again how
an electronic guided workflow can help
you
to force your data integrity
initiative
yeah here we have also very important um
topic and this is backing up your
instrument data
especially for a standalone laboratory
instrument like a balance we have quite
often the case that you take care about
your process data like the single
weighing result but what is with all the
other data on the instrument
like
auto trail calibration logs and method
configuration for example
they are also gxp relevant and has to be
stored over the
entire data life cycle
but when you only store the data on the
instrument
you can have the problem that the
instrument broken
and then you also lose your data and
therefore you should also have the
possibility to back up these instrument
data
in a secure place in an optimal case um
it's like
our qs2 balance that you can transfer
automatically in a regular
way the data to network storage and um
yeah also another point is
that you can also have um
the readability of these data in 10 20
years and therefore you should make sure
that only standard file formats like pdf
are used that are also readable in
future
yeah in our next example you can also
see
how a modern laboratory instrument with
digital guidance on the instrument can
help you
to avoid
any problems
in this fda finding
that was mentioned you failed to
challenge the analytical balances for
minimum weight measurement for
uncertainty
and drift value
and
here
we can easily avoid for example with our
keywords to balance because on one hand
we have implemented
workflows that helps you to determinate
the working range of your laboratory
balance
and on the other hand we can make sure
that there is no weighing below this
minimum sample weight so otherwise the
workflow on the instrument
blocks the takeover of the measurement
and on the other side we can also
automatically display and document the
measurement uncertainty for each
weighing value directly on the
instruments so you can also see here
that digitalization helps you a lot to
avoid problems and document things
automatically yeah in my last
fda finding i would like to highlight
the importancy to monitor the status of
your computerized system because
when you have some male functionalities
like power interruptions or connectivity
problem
this can also lead to loose data
on your system and therefore you should
always monitor
the system status and also investigate
when there are some male functionalities
therefore the instrument should bring
some functionalities that you easily can
see what is the current status of the
system and also have some log files what
you can review on a regular base for
later investigations
and it's also very important that all
the messages on the systems are in a
natural language so that everyone direct
dc
if there is any male functionality and
what is the male functionality so for
example with the cubist ii balance we
have
a clear status center where you directly
see what is the current status on the
instrument
and we have also the police the
possibility to block
the
weighing
when there is any male functionality to
avoid that
anyone performs weighing jobs without a
proper instrument
so at the end i would like to summarize
all the features that an computerized
system should provide to automate
processes as much as possible and to
support your
data integrity initiatives
this are
a backup functionality for all the gxp
relevant data like process data but also
audit trails
then it should have an auto trail
functionality
that locks all the events
in the system and especially for
laboratory balances it should also bring
comes with a alibi memory
where all the weighing results are
stored
as a reference
yeah then the instrument should come
within proper access control and user
management so that user
always
have to log in with a personal
account for a high traceability and have
all the the rights what they need for
the daily work
yeah then it should provide an
electronic signature functionality
and automatically time synchronization
that you always have the correct time on
the instrument
and it should have a proper digital user
guidance
that
your
employees have to follow your sop that
the data is automatically
locked and if there is any mail
functionality or
any out of specification result the user
is warned
yeah thank you very much for
participating in the presentation part
one
i hope i was able to show you how a
computerized system can prevent data
integrity problems and increase
efficiency in the lab
all examples were shown by using the
cubist 2 balance from saturios which is
a standalone instrument with full 21
part 11 compliance and extensive
connectivity options without any
additional
software or middleware need cubist2 is a
fully configurable weighing platform
that can be customized to your needs
and if you want to have more
informations about this please visit our
homepage sartorios.com
i will now take over to the second part
of the presentation to my colleague
holger denzo thank you
in this presentation i will talk about
the new chapter 2.1.7 of the european
thermocopia
i will highlight the differences to the
usp chapter 41 and i will talk about
tutorial software solutions to cover
this topic
i will start to talk general aspects of
the new chapter since the differences to
the usb chapter 41
upgrades to the queue up's minimum
weight and usb advance and in the end i
will give a short summary
the new chapter of the european
pharmacopoeia deals with balances for
analytical purposes
it became mandatory on the 1st of
january this year
and affects pharmaceutical companies
manufacturing drugs for the european
market
so this new regulation does not only
affect companies located within the
european union
but manufacturing drugs for the european
union
the new chapter focuses on best
practices for installation and usage of
instruments and highlights the
importance of calibrations and the
documentation a certificate including
the measurement uncertainty
and supports the life science management
of instruments based on the performed
tests and calibrations
the european pharmacopoeia chapter 2.1.7
lists a lot of general considerations
for analytical balances like for example
it defines the si units as force is mass
multiplied by gravity
it defines a balanced side mechanical
electronical and the resolution
and it deals with installation and
location
the new chapter gives clear guidance how
to monitor environmental conditions at
the insulation side
like temperature
humidity and barometric pressure
and gives recommendations how to avoid
air carbons
dust electrostatic forces magnetic
forces and
vibrations to deal with these topics
satorius offers different technical
solutions and these are mentioned in
brackets on the slide
to measure environmental conditions and
the installation side we offer climate
modules and a software for air buoyancy
correction
to avoid air currents and dust special
glass trees weighing pen or covers can
be used
for the elimination of electrostatic
forces and magnetic forces ionizers and
antimagnetic weighing plants are
available
and to avoid vibrations weighing tables
can be used
in addition to these general
considerations
chapter
2.1.7 also deals with the equipment
performance
in detail about calibrations and
performance checks
regarding the performance checks there
are some differences between the
european pharmacopoeia chapter 2.1.7
and the usp chapter 41.
on the next slides i'm going to talk
about the similarities and differences
between the two chapters
the performance checks include a
repeatability and accuracy test and the
insulation side
but there are some differences between
the two chapters
according to the european pharmacopoeia
the systematic errors determined in the
accuracy test must not be greater than
0.05 percent
so this limit is more strict than in the
usp chapter 41
because according to usp 0.1 percent are
allowed
in addition the european pharmacoplia
gives clear guidelines on the test loads
for the repeatability test the test load
should be between 100 milligram and 5
percent of the maximum balance capacity
and for the sensitivity test the test
load must be between 5 and 100
usb chapter 41 doesn't give that clear
guidelines on the test load and in
theory
the performance checks could be passed
using only one single test load
so conducting performance checks
complying to usb chapter 41
does not necessarily lead to compliance
to the european pharmacopoeia chapter
2.1.7
concerning some other aspects usp
chapter 41 and the european
pharmacopoeia chapter 2.1.7
do not differ
according to both chapters
the performance checks must be conducted
as instruments installation site
using the standard deviation s of the
repeatability measurement with at least
10 repetitions the minimum sample weight
is calculated
to calculate the minimum weight
the standard deviation is multiplied by
2000. if the standard deviation is lower
than 0.41
this equation is replaced by 2000
multiplied by 0.41 multiplied by the
scale interval
so in consequence the calculated minimum
sample weight cannot be lower than 820
multiplied by the balanced scale
interval
since the performance checks are
conducted in the installation side and
the standard deviation s is taken for
the calculation the ambient conditions
are considered for the calculation of
the minimum sample rate
according to both chapters
the performance checks should be
conducted at regular intervals and of
course the measurements shall be
repeated if the balance is moved
so the minimum sample weight limit is
identical
but the requirements on the performance
checks are slightly different between
the two chapters
so what solutions are available from
sartorius to maintain compliance to the
new european pharmacopoeia chapter 2.1.7
satorius offers two software solutions
so-called q apps
for cubist 2 balances to cover the
requirements of the new chapter 2.1.7
the first software application minimum
weight
controls at no weight values below the
allowed minimum sample weight are
acquired
the second software application usb
advanced offers guided workflows for
performance checks
to determine the permissible minimum
sample rate
software application minimum weight
allows to select between different
guidelines like usp chapter 41
the european pharmacopoeia chapter 2.1.7
and euromet cg18
min or user defined
the software application allows to set
the starting point of operating range
also called our min value that is given
on the balance calibration protocol
if the minimum sample rate according to
usp or the european pharmacoplasty set
the software application includes a
plausibility check for 820 digits
so based on the balanced scale interval
the software application checks that no
minimal sample weight below the lowest
alloy limit is entered
if the function set weight values below
the minimum weight to invalid is
activated
the minimum sample weight is shown in
red in the weighing screen and the
takeover button is inactivated
using this mode the acquisition of
weight values below the allowed minimum
sample weight is
blocked alternatively to determine the
minimum sample weighed by a balanced
calibration the software application usp
advanced can be used
the software application allows to
conduct a performance check according to
usp or the european pharmacopoeia
and it displays recommendations for the
test loads
if the european pharmacopoeia is
selected
the software application offers a guided
workflow for the sensitivity and
repeatability test
in combination with the compatibility
check of the determined minimum sample
weight
at the end of the test the user gets an
information displayed if they calculate
a minimum sample weight complies to the
requirements
the screen additionally offers to set
the minimum sample weight that is then
used by the software application minimum
weight
as discussed before the software
application minimum weight can control
that no sample weights below the
permissible minimum weight
are acquired
before i will give a final summary just
a few words on the minimal sample weight
and its usage in the pharmaceutical
industry
according to usp and the european
pharmacopoeia it is forbidden to acquire
sample weights below the minimum weight
so in best case 820 multiplied by the
scale interval
the effective minimum sample weight for
balance depends on the environment so
the installation side and the ambient
conditions
it's important to know that by
definition the minimum sample weight
refers to net values so using a high
tear weight does not lead to a higher
permissible minimum sample weight
instead the balance sensitivity must be
high enough and the balance must be
installed under good conditions to offer
a low minimum sample weight
using vessels with high tear weight is
not a solution and in worst case the fda
issues warning letters if usb chapter 41
is violated
in summary the european pharmacopoeia
chapter 2.1.7
defines the general requirements for
analytical balances used in the
pharmaceutical industry
the minimum weight is defined like an
usb 820 digits or higher
it provides clear guidance on test loads
used for the repeatability and
sensitivity test
and it has a tighter requirement on the
systematic errors in the usp
0.05 percent versus 0.1 percent
to maintain compliance
sartorius modified the queue app's
minimum weight and usp advanced
according to the european pharmacopoeia
chapter 2.1.7
in the software application minimum
weight the user can select between
different guidelines now and a check for
820 digits has been implemented to the
software application usb advanced a
performance check procedure according to
the european pharmacopoeia has been
added
the software application checks if the
determined value for the minimum sample
weight complies with usp
of european pharmacopoeia requirements
if the value is compliant it can be set
by the software and used by the software
application minimum weight
to prevent the acquisition of weight
values below the minimum sample rate
thank you very much for joining our
presentation today i hope we gave you
some new insights into the topic of
compliance for laboratory balances
please feel free to ask us if you have
any questions or visit our website
if you want to have more information
about the presented instruments
thank you dr denzo for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
all right let's get started our first
question here asks do i have to
administrate users at the balance or can
i connect the balance to out ldap server
that's a great question
well um of course you can administrate
users at the balance but if you own many
balances and you're working in a larger
company or a larger lab and it gets
cumbersome
yeah
administrate all users on all balances
so
yes the answer is you can hook up the
balance to your local ldap server
and
then easy users are
created on demand and the balance and
they can use your their windows or linux
password
that's possible
so using an ldap server is a far easier
way to administrate
the balances
and
to keep the user management up to date
than
doing it locally on the buttons
great thank you
next question here
what happens in case of a power failure
is measurement data getting lost
well if
the balance
has got a power failure
and
if you are working in a task in the
waiting task and as a power switch is
off
the reporting data will get lost
but
not the measurement data
so in fact the balance collects data in
the reporting
queue
and
in the raw data
memory
so the raw data memory is a so-called
led memory
and
here measurement data are written
immediately into the memory so this data
this data is not getting lost
and
only reported reports are getting lost
so you can always have a look to the led
memory
if in case of a power failure and
you can have a look
which values were recorded by the puzzle
ballots
great
another question we have here
asks if the balance exports results to a
server how is the data protected against
manipulation
so how how can i be sure the data
integrity is maintained
okay there we
also a good question because uh
if you export data to a server you can
as a pdf file or csv file or whatever
of course
this data
could potentially be manipulated by
users
and
a protection against these manipulations
is on the following mechanism
so
all reports the balance exports
have an additional checksum
and
this checksum is also
entered in the audit trail
so whenever
you're in doubt of your data integrity
we can check the original um checksum
of
your exported files
and
first of all
for the exported file the checksum
doesn't match
um
you can be sure there has been something
manipulated
and
the second mechanism is to
additionally control the original
checksum in the outer trail because also
the checksum might be manipulated
but as a balance um in the other trails
the checksum
cannot be manipulated that is recorded
so you have got always
let's say
a raw data of the
original
checksum and
by comparing these checksums in the
original files
you can always find out if your
files have been manipulated or not
great
well it looks like we have time for one
more question here so we'll wrap up with
this one
is the balance 21 cfr part 11 compliant
or does it support compliance
the balance
itself can not be
21 0.11 compliant
because according to the fta guideline
also some measures have
have to be taken by the
users
here in a detailed it environment
of the lab
so the balance alone cannot be cfr
compliant um but with the right measures
and of your it department um the
complete system can be
compliant
for the balance
for the curves to balance off
subterminus we offer a cfr compliance
checklist and in this checklist you can
see
how the balance matches this cfr
compliance
and
for which requirements and we have got
to take measures
in your rt environment
so i guess the question is somehow a
little bit um
the aim of the question is somehow can i
get something like a
statement or a certificate the balance
is cfr compliant
and the answer is no
because uh
cit also has to
take some measures
to support these cfr compliance
was abandoned alone no
right
well thank you again dr denzo for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor sartorius for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye
you